wenn du dass deine hammer schenks die
wird sich freuen das hat keiner kummer
und echt ein bisschen billig aus dass
das hart voll das ist jetzt nicht so
naiv
hey leute was geht ab und herzlich
willkommen zu einem neuen video ja leute
ich hoffe natürlich geht es gut wir
befinden uns hier in meiner reaction
ecke juli ist heute leider nicht dabei
deswegen habe ich beschlossen dieses
video ganz entspannt hier auch
aufzunehmen
auf diesem wunderschön auf diesem
wunderschönen stuhl und heute haben wir
was interessantes vor der eine oder
andere von euch hat sicherlich gesehen
ich konnte mir vor drei wochen ich habe
dazu waren video gemacht für 400 euro
bayerisch aussuchen was ich will die
agenturen hat euro gutschein zur
verfügung gestellt was jetzt in zukunft
denke ich öfter passiert das heißt alle
produkte die ich da er werbe kriege ich
praktisch auch umsonst
dann kann ich noch mehr videos machen
das problem ist halt leider nur ich
hatte natürlich auch davor schon selber
wieder sachen bestellt bei irgendwelchen
shops weil ich das total feiere einfach
diese ganzen sachen immer auszupacken
und euch zu zeigen
und wir haben ja den corona virus und
wir haben auch noch john isner oder wir
hatten kein isolierter arbeiten die
ganzen chinesen nicht und dadurch
verzögern sich diese lieferzeiten extrem
weswegen ganz ganz viele sachen noch
fehlen ich habe jetzt allerdings fünf
iphone-handy case ist wirklich sehr
verrückte iphone-handy cases bereits
bekommen
die liegen hier auch schon also ich
hoffe dass sie das alles sind und die
wollte ich euch auf jeden fall zeigen
also ich wollte sowieso ein video dazu
machen damit das ganze vielleicht noch
ein bisschen spannender wird ich war
gestern mit marie zusammen bei saturn
die hat sich ein neues handy gekauft und
da habe ich dann auch nochmal zwei
iphone cases mitgenommen der unterschied
ist im saturn kosten die zwischen 20 und
5 50 euro bayerisch zwischen 2 und 10
ja und ich habe mich wirklich gefragt
das ist ein stück plastik ist dieses
stück plastik 55 euro wert also ich
würde niemals 550 euro finde handy hülle
ausgeben
zumal ich eh keine handybenutzer ich
weiß dass es vielleicht ein bisschen
dumm aber habe stelle ich mir lieber im
internet irgendwo eine für drei wirklich
ich weiß nicht wie ihr das seht sind
eure meinung nach diese preise
gerechtfertigt oder nicht könnte ja gern
mein gekommen
schreiben und ich würde sagen ich zeige
euch jetzt erstmal die ganzen sachen die
ich gekauft habe und bin mal gespannt
wenn ich dir auspackt wir haben hier als
erstes diese luxury bling diamond metal
bumper case fünf euro 70 ich habe
übrigens cases für iphone 7 plus und
auch fürs iphone 11 meiner meinung nach
bestellt 75 und 5 euro versand also 10
eur 70 ist die teuerste glaube ich die
ich da erworben habe ich hoffe dir ist
schon da und als nächstes haben wir dann
hier dieses karton case für iphone
sieben und acht mal die kannst du dein
altes iphone 7 rummachen für vier euro
insgesamt ja zwei euro das produkt und
zwei euro versand das ist rechne ich als
fairer weise immer zusammen sonst habe
ich immer einfach nur den produktpreis
hier genannt dann haben wir hier noch
diese rahmen fashion bling diamond bunny
rapid case für iphone 7 plus extrem
heftig ich glaube das ist mein favourit
zu auch wenn ich die persönlich
natürlich nicht benutze die kostet 3
euro plus 4 euro versand sieben euro und
dann haben wir hier noch dieses coca
cola case für insgesamt vier euro also
an sich preise die ich in ordnung finde
absolut und meiner meinung nach sollte
so ein stück plastik auch nicht mehr
kosten dann würde ich sagen wir machen
jetzt einfach mal auf und fangen
natürlich mit den produkten von wish an
let's go ok also ich werde euch
natürlich immer nach aufnahmen auch von
den produkten einblenden wir fangen wir
erstmal mit diesem wunderschönen produkt
okay leute wir haben hier eine simple
hülle die habe ich euch grad gar nicht
gezeigt werde ich euch jetzt im
nachhinein noch einen blenden wie teuer
die war das okay interessant die passt
schön auf mein iphone 7 plus und ich
muss ganz ehrlich sagen feiere ich sogar
geiles case ja gefällt mir ich würde mal
sagen die hat maximal fünf euro kostet
mit versand also die hülle die ich am
besten finde lasse ich bei mir dran die
anderen höhlen sowie auch die vom saturn
werden bei instagram verlost in einer
story die schicke ich euch dazu könnt
ihr dann einfach auf meine story antwort
und dann werde ich da fünf sechs leute
auswählen oder apple stellt euch die
halt einfach selber für fünf euro dauert
dann halt nur sehr lange bis sie
ankommen okay machen wir weiter mit der
nächsten hülle
ich bin mal gespannt was das jetzt ist
ob ich die euch bis jetzt auch noch
nicht gezeigt haben wir die scan ist
hülle marie können sie mir immer dein
iphone 7 geben ich habe mir nämlich
extra für dich mit bestellt weil ich da
noch nicht wusste dass du dir neues
handy holt also die feier auch heftig
ohne scheiß vier euro kann man nicht
meckern
guck mal vier euro die jetzt jedoch
aufnehmen können sowas oder wirst du
deine hülle für 40 euro bevorzugen
30 okay die ist wirklich ein bisschen
hässlich aber sehr ausgefallen und wer
hat mittels kittels hülle keiner also
damit seid ihr in der schule der
absolute überkingen vielleicht
vielleicht werdet ihr auch ausgelacht
ich vielleicht es nicht okay das war mir
fällt auf ich habe die ganze zeit
kopfhörer im ohr das ohne schnaps nicht
gemerkt das sollte jetzt nicht irgendwie
es sind auch nur die ganz einfachen
airport zu sind ja nicht es sind ja
nicht mal airport von daher so jetzt
jetzt nicht viel
jetzt merke ich gerade schon hier wird
es ein bisschen schwerer ja da ist
bisschen mehr qualität hinter hat
vielleicht handelt es sich um die das
ist hier das luxury case ist das kaputt
gebrochen
es muss wahrscheinlich so ok hier
verstehe ich denn jetzt auch warum das
ein bisschen teurer war
wir müssen das selber noch zusammenbauen
ich muss jetzt mal kurz gucken wie man
das neue liegt jetzt auch weil ich hier
hin die veranstalter aber das kann ich
absolut verstehen
also ich muss gerade auch direkt mal
sagen ich finde das sieht irgendwie auf
diesem bild viel geiler aus als jetzt
hier
wir machen das jetzt mal hier rum aber
man wird dadurch wird ja auch
automatisch die kamera zugeklebt ja ich
verstehe jetzt aber gar nicht wo da der
sinn ist das muss man jetzt manuell
drauf ach so kuck mal leute leute ich
habe das jetzt abgezogen und diese
sachen bleiben automatisch kleben und
man kann die folie
man kann die folie jetzt perfekt hier
hinten dann einfach draufkleben emery
ganz ehrlich gebt ihr mann das wäre so
ein geist iphone sieglos wenn du dass
deine hammer schenks die wird sich
freuen
das hat keiner kummer nicht wo geht das
sieht echt ein bisschen billig aus aber
für zehn euro finde ich das eigentlich
in ordnung habe ich würde es mir als
private nicht wurden also das kann ich
euch ehrlicherweise nicht empfehlen holt
euch lieber ein case was direkt ganz ist
auch wenn man das hier gar nicht so
wirklich entnehmen kann dass man dass
man das so selber zusammenbauen muss es
zur schädigung ich mach's gleich ab so
jetzt fast auf bevor du dich weiter auf
tricks jetzt kommt die krassesten fülle
wir haben ja einfach so leute ja dass
das hart voll das ist jetzt nicht so
nice hat halt auch nur 3 euro gekostet
oder so
das ist scheiße das dürfte nicht
passieren wir haben ja wirklich so eine
feier ist also für so kleine mädels ist
das doch was oder das was für tic toc
das sieht das hat richtig tickt
potenzial dann mache ich so vom spiegel
so ein tick tock und dann mache ich so
und dann fällt es so zu ok nur spaß
leute irgendwie ist dieses case ein
bisschen dumm ich mein wenn du ein foto
machen willst siehst du nichts und wenn
du was sehen willst kannst kein foto
machen also h ja das waren jetzt vier
sehr verrückte cases von wish für drei
bis zehn euro
und jetzt schauen wir uns mal die an die
wir hier in deutschland gekauft haben
für 19 euro 99 und für 29 99
fangen wir mal hier mit an wir haben
hier eine
wir haben ja ein ganz normales
durchsichtiges case für iphone elf von
der marke art swift 19 eur 990 hat das
gekostet und da bin ich jetzt mal
gespannt ob ich da auch wirklich
qualitativen unterschied erkennen also
dies auf jeden fall schon mal ein
bisschen professioneller eingepackt das
muss man ganz klar sagen kannst du dein
iphone elf geben aber das war's dann
halt auch schon und dieses plastik das
gibts doch auch bairisch dass er für
neue küsse gratis ein bisschen schade
ist es dass ich so ein durchsichtiges
kann es jetzt nicht über wulffs bestellt
habe das wäre vielleicht ganz cool
gewesen
man muss sagen die qualität hiervon ist
besser als das hier allemal
aber obwohl na ja geht wirklich gar
nicht mal sagen das hier ist einfach nur
hier ist halten druck drauf ok marie
sagt die fühlt sich unangenehm an und
die nicht ich sage mir wäre das komplett
egal
also ich finde dass auch hier das ist in
ordnung das ist halt so gummi zeigt
keine ahnung von dürfen uns diese hier
bei sonne also meine meinung ist ich
würde dafür niemals 19 eur 990 bezahlen
einfach weil ich mir sicher bin dass das
in der produktion maximal 20 cent kostet
aber gut
marie wird das ausgeben hat sie ja auch
also beziehungsweise ich schenke ich dir
und als nächstes habe ich dann hier noch
ja die hat mir gekauft aber ich zeige
euch trotzdem eine einigen of sweden
hülle für 30 euro gibt es auch im
internet eigentlich ne kosten jeder
genau so viel also die haben jetzt bei
saturn gekauft und ich muss ganz ehrlich
sagen das hier ist einfach nur
hartplastik oder so 30 euro also das ist
eine frechheit dass sie zwar auf jeden
fall qualitativ besser aus oder es ist
natürlich auch qualitativ ein bisschen
besser aber 30 euro dafür
den sehr schnell kaputt so hier haben
wir ihre alte hülle kann man ja sehen
die ab sondern es ist interessant ich
glaube das wird hier mit der
zinsentscheidung nicht passieren da ist
ja so also ich würde es nicht einsehen
im saturn 30 euro für seine hülle zu
bezahlen ich würde vielleicht bei amazon
schauen oder bayerisch oder sonstwo und
mir dahin bestellen
ja die ist ein bisschen stimmt die hülle
ist einfach falsch rum hier haben wir
zwei button aber hier ist ja an und aus
knopf und die haben wir nur ein button
mit dem man halt dann die ganze zeit
leider macht schreibt gern mal dazu in
die kommentare was ihr dazu denkt klar
das ist bei fast allen sachen so dass
wenn man die dann hier in deutschland im
laden kauft das natürlich viel teurer
ist als wenn man es irgendwo im internet
bestellt dann stellt sich natürlich auch
mal die frage zu welchen konditionen ist
das hergestellt aber ich bin der meinung
dass der herstellungsprozess von seiner
handy keine 20 euro erfordert ich meine
da werden wahrscheinlich 1000 stück in
zwei minuten produziert und aber
vielleicht liege ich damit auch falsch
ich weiß nicht schreibt eure meinung in
den kommentaren danke fürs zuschauen wir
sehen uns übermorgen wieder gibt es
neues video
haut rein